there is definitely a point in three
days to kill or it becomes very apparent
that we are watching a Mik G film it's
right around the time where a child's
reaction to witnessing a multiple
homicide as well as a car bomb go off is
yes three days to kill is directed by
Mick G and stars Kevin Costner Amber
Heard Hailee Steinfeld and Connie
Nielsen Kevin Costner plays a secret
agent who didn't really have that much
time to spend with his daughter Hailee
Steinfeld as she grew up he's trying to
mend their relationship because he's
discovered that he's going to be dying
in a few months due to cancer all the
while sexy secret agent temptress Amber
Heard is trying to get him back into the
field for one last job now I love Kevin
Costner I've always liked him Field of
Dreams really inspired me a lot when I
was younger I watched head movie more
times than I can remember I've always
liked him as an actor and a director
Dances with Wolves was very good and
open range is actually a very underrated
Western if you haven't checked that out
he directed it it's pretty good this
movie is not directed by him it is
directed by Mick G and Mick G is not one
of my favorite directors he generally
tends to make very similar films films
that are about secret agents or spies
with a very comedic twist to it that
have a lot of absurd scenes we've seen
this before and really is it something I
really enjoy watching and unfortunately
with three days to kill I had the same
thought however there are two bright
spots in this movie that of Kevin
Costner and Hailee Steinfeld these two
have excellent chemistry with one
another and are fantastic in this movie
in their roles
I thought Hailee Steinfeld here this is
the best I've seen her since True Grit
she really gave a lot of character to
her character and she really added a lot
to her scene she was very realistic I
totally bought her as this kind of
bratty teenager but she also had a great
heart to her character and not just
because of the way it was written
she really was authentic in this role
and she really totally celled herself in
scenes with Kevin Costner who is like a
living legend in regards to movies Kevin
Costner is great in this movie I really
liked his character I liked the way he
played the character however the movie
is really dumb this movie is better than
this Means War but it has basically the
same problem it's a film that's trying
to have a very serious story to it with
a lot of spy operations and stuff but
then it tries to throw in all the
family and relationship drama along with
this really absurd comedy that just
doesn't make sense also the movie is
directed really poorly and I'm not
talking necessarily about the way it
looks because it's a sleek-looking movie
I'm talking about the way scenes are
assembled there are intense scenes in
this movie that would be entertaining if
they weren't just so out of the blue
there isn't really a good sequence of
events in this movie in which you are
able to ride a tone that feels as if it
flows naturally everything is jumbled
and certain things happen where you're
like that was just out of nowhere like
chase scenes that just boom here's a big
chase scene where did this come from why
is this here besides to have the cliched
and we need a chase scene right now and
it really isn't all that well directed
it's just this hyperactive editing style
that McGee loves to use also towards the
finale of this movie there are certain
events that are just glossed over
entirely that should be really really
important but are never discussed it's
all just sort of like faded into a
couple sentences with narration where
you're supposed to be like okay so I
guess that's what happened there are
certain conversations you're kind of
waiting the whole movie for characters
to have with one another and they're
never had it's such a cop-out the way
this movie ends the way certain
characters and their arcs are just left
hanging as if they're suspended in
midair where you'll never actually know
where certain things were going and it's
very disappointing to see some of these
likeable characters have absolutely no
arc or conclusion to their story and it
all just feels like it shined over by
this Hollywood ending that doesn't
really make you happy because you're
just wondering where certain characters
are going to end up so like I said Kevin
Costner is good in this movie Hailee
Steinfeld is good in this movie Amber
Heard is really good to look at in this
movie but she came off as an Austin
Powers secret agent like she was just a
joke really she just was so over the top
so a really likable lead performance
from Kevin Costner that I just want to
be like look dude you're in an awesome
movie but unfortunately it's not because
this story is so silly and over-the-top
but it doesn't hit the right tone it's
just so jumbled and it feels like your
average Mick G spy movie with all this
crazy forced humor thrown in there that
just doesn't really work I'm going to
give three days to kill a c-minus it's
not really worth seeing in the theaters
I would suggest Kevin Costner
checking it out for a really good
performance from him but other than that
this movie just really isn't worth your
time guys if you see the movie let me
know what you thought of it below I'm
curious to know what's your favorite
Mick G movie mine's probably we are
Marshall I would say that's the one
bright spot in regards to the films he's
made that just does not seem like McGee
movie at all thanks as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]